CHANTING "IF WE DON’T GET
JUSTICE YOU DON’T GET SLEEP.
NEW YORK CITY IS IN A STATE OF
CRISIS AND TO TOP IT OFF
HOMELESSNESS, DRUG USE SPIRALING
OUT OF CONTROL IN PUBLIC VIEW.
IT HAS BECOME SO BAD ONE FOUR
STAR HOTEL IS A HOMELESS SHELTER
FOR DRUG ADDICTS.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT FROM
"THE NEW YORK POST," MOUNT
TOWN -- DOWNTOWN MATT HATTON AND
THE UPPER EASTSIDE NOW FILLED
WITH ADDICTS SHOOTING HEROIN IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT IN FULL PUBLIC
VIEW.
IT IS SO BAD DISCARDED NEEDLES
ARE LINING THE STREETS, WHICH
BRINGS US TO TONIGHT’S "HANNITY"
SPECIAL INVESTIGATION.
WE SENT OUR 2020 CORRESPONDENT
LAWRENCE JONES TO NEW YORK TO
FIND OUT EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING
ON AND WHAT HE FOUND SHOULD
SHOCK THE CONSCIOUS.
BUT REMEMBER A PREVIEW OF COMING
ATTRACTIONS IF BIDEN’S AMERICA
COMES A REALITY AND I TO SEVEN
DAYS.
FOX NEWS, CORRESPONDENT 2020
CORRESPONDENT INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER LAWRENCE JONES.
YOU LEARNED A LOT TODAY.
>> GOOD EVENING, IT SHONE AND WE
HAVE BEEN COVERING AMERICAN
CITIES IN CRISIS AND THE CITIES
HAPPEN TO BE RUN BY
DEMOCRATIC MAYORS AND
NEW YORK CITY ISN’T ANY
DIFFERENT.
RESIDENTS ARE FURIOUS ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS OPENLY SHOOTING UP
WITH DRUGS WITH NEEDLES AND
PLACE THE BLAME SQUARELY WITHIN
THE MAYOR BILL de BLASIO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> >> THREE MONTHS WE HAVE BEEN
HERE SINCE THE SHUTDOWN EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
SHOOT UP.
WE HAVE A CIGARETTE AND THEY
ATTACK US.
>> WHAT DO THE LEADERS DO?
>> NOTHING.
>> AND YOU SAY IT’S NOT THAT
BAD.
>> BY COMPARISON, YOU KNOW, I
DON’T EVEN SEE IT ANYMORE.
I AM KIND OF NUMB TO THE WHOLE
THING, PEOPLE SHOOTING AT US.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK NEW YORK
BEING COMPARED TO SAN FRANCISCO,
SKID ROW?
>> IT’S GETTING THERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> WHO DO YOU BLAME FOR ALL OF
IT?
THE MAYOR de BLASIO.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> NEVER, EVER.
>> NOW, SEAN, IF THAT WAS ONLY
BAD ENOUGH THE CAP OF THE
NEEDLES EVERYWHERE.
THEY DECIDED TO CLEAN IT UP
AFTER "THE NEW YORK POST"
REPORT.
BUT NOW THEY ARE PUTTING
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN
FOUR-STAR HOTELS.
THE ONLY THING IS, THEY DIDN’T
TELL THE RESIDENTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY STAYING IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
THEY AREN’T HAPPY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THEY MOVE THE HOMELESS
POPULATION ACROSS THE STREET
HERE.
ARE YOU CONCERNED?
>> I’M A BIT CONCERNED,
ESPECIALLY AS A WOMAN AT NIGHT
BECAUSE I WORK AT NIGHT.
I COME HOME LATE.
AND DURING THE DAY, I SAW ONE
GUY HOPE AND OTHER GUY ACROSS
THE STREET WHO IS ON DRUGS.
>> THE WHOLE DYNAMICS OF THE
COMMUNITY HAS CHANGED.
>> DO YOU SUPPORT THEM DOING
THIS TO YOUR COMMUNITY?
>> NOT REALLY.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE --
>> ABSOLUTELY, ABSOLUTELY.
>> THE COVID.
YOU HAVE TO PUT THEM SOMEWHERE.
YOU HAVE TO PUT THEM IN
INDIVIDUAL ROOMS.
AND I THINK IT IS WELL FORMATTED
AND SUPERVISED.
>> I HAVE SEEN SO MANY DRUG
DEALS GO DOWN.
I DON’T WANT THOSE DAYS TO COME
BACK.
>> SEAN, AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE
VIDEO, THE LOCAL BUSINESSES HAVE
TO HIRE SECURITY TO PROTECT THE
PATRONS FROM THE HOMELESS PEOPLE
THAT ARE STRUNG OUT ON DRUGS.
THE PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR, THEY ARE NOT ANTI-GETTING
HOMELESS HELP HERE THEY WANT TO
BE CONSULTED AND THE FOUR-STAR
HOTEL REALLY THE PLACE TO PUT
THEM?
BACK TO YOU, SEAN.
>> Sean: AND USE ALL PEOPLE
LITERALLY SHOOTING UP.
WE ARE NOT TALKING WHAT WE KNOW
MORE CRIME-RIDDEN AREAS IN
NEW YORK, WE SAW MIDTOWN, THE
FULL EXTENSIVE UPPER EAST SIDE
OF NEW YORK?
>> >> WE ARE TALKING THE SIDE,
NOT ONLY SHOOTING UP, BUT WE SAW
THEM PREPPING THE DRUGS RIGHT IN
THIS AREA AS WELL.
AND OF COURSE, WHEN I TALK TO
RESIDENTS THAT SAY, WHY AREN’T
THE POLICE ENFORCING THE LAWS
THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS?
THEY BLAME THE MAYOR FOR THE
DEFUND THE POLICE MESSAGE THAT
HE HAD TO SPANNING THE
ANTI-CRIME UNIT.
THEY FEEL LIKE THE OFFICERS THEY
USE TO SEE ON A DAY-TO-DAY BASIS
FEEL LIKE THEIR HANDS ARE TIED.
THEY DON’T WANT TO LOSE THEIR
JOBS OR THEIR LIKELIHOOD TO.
>> Sean: THEN YOU ALSO SEE
PEOPLE -- I’VE SEEN PICTURES OF
AND NOT UNLIKE SAN FRANCISCO, ON
THE STREETS.
>> WE SAW THAT SEAN AND WE
TALKED TO ONE PERSON NEW YORK
RESIDENT WHO USED TO BE IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND HE SAID HE